oh my god trees thank you so much for
having coffee with us today we know
you're so busy and popular and like oh
my god it is such an honor trees I mean
like first of all aren't you just
letting a platter a buffet is that can
be only at the best food ever
first of all did God create you feel
like ma this is the only thing that I
want to be but the hottest on earth
first of all like I can just feel the
golden energy coming off you like I
could sell you at a pawn shop there are
no beds I got he that's got you a
cupcake trees
I'm not eating solid foods doesn't yeah
that's stupid of me
stupid cupcake drop it leave it at me
it's just stupid every to get even
company this spring of my grandma she's
thinking with like happiness and it's
not so anyways you know Jeff the hot guy
at work yeah yeah so he sent hiding me
the other day that's so funny because
Jeff said by any the other day yeah he
spotted me the other day
well Jeff he was like here you want this
link with me and I'm not hungry you can
have it ma yeah
Jeff put his hoodie on top of my
kneecaps and you said here you go cuz
they're cold and hairy little cute
grandma chef to me moment on a private
jet than a strike in marriage in the
middle of Tiffany it's like if it got
any ring I wanted like well Jeff he gave
me a diamond encrusted princess trunks
he said you are princess sitting at her
throne and you're gonna become my queen
someday oh my gosh Jeff brought me a
packet of Hello Kitty pencils and he had
a Hello Kitty eraser and he threw it at
my nipple oh my gosh Jeff Hardy about
our honeymoon tickets
iris Neela's Space Shuttle and more
seats are in between Leonardo DiCaprio
and Tom Hanks and we're sitting on there
laughs well I have to go we have to go
to we really have to go no so Theresa
same time tomorrow
same time tomorrow Oh Theresa was such
an honor
you